was it weird when you walked away from
that show did you lose a lot of
friendships i don't mean like overtly
someone goes well i'm not gonna be
friends with you anymore but you were
the queen of uh that whole thing you
could make stars and you could break
stars well i never thought that people
have said that to me and one person i
did you see the tape of anne hey saying
that um
i had harassed her in her dressing room
yeah i didn't see the tape but i heard
about it wha what was that all about she
had that same idea that you did that i
could make or break people which never
occurred to me while i was there except
for a broadway show that i tried to
really buoy up some shows that i i loved
but
ann hayes gets in this accident and i'm
bereft now how did i know her she did my
show twice
and um she and ellen came to my home in
miami and swam in my pool and we had
lunch once so i knew her
you know not really well but in the
celebrity vernacular and that she was
with ellen for a while and then how her
career suffered and her book called me
crazy there was a terribly
horribly tragic child abuse in that
family and i've always sort of felt
sorry for it so when she's dying when
that all happens i'm legitimately bereft
in a way that maybe surprised me i'd
wake up in the morning and think oh my
god something's wrong oh ann hey she's
in a coma like it was obsessive to me
so she she died tragically
somebody says did you see this tape i
said what tape
they said a year ago she had a podcast
and on the tape she's talking and she's
very very very you know
either in a manic state or sort of maybe
high but she was saying i went actually
to the rosie o'donnell show and you know
rosie o'donnell herself walked in and
said to me and if you mention anything
gay of the world you think you're in
that you're doing things for gay people
if you mention anything like that then
i'm going to ruin your career i will
blackball you and blacklist you and you
will never be this show will never see
the light of day and that's what she
said to me no i'm at home listening to
this i'm sh in shock
i call my my nephew who does all the
tapes for us i go pull every animation
of you
first interview she did we didn't talk
about ellen uh at all um but i said to
her at the end nice to meet you so i had
never met her before then right right
so then the second one we talked all
about ellen she was only on twice and
she said in these interviews she was on
for donnie brasco she never did my show
for donnie brasco so she was confused i
think about something but the concept
that she walked around
feeling that about me for 20 something
years kind of broke my heart a little
bit
that you a gay woman would say to her if
you talk about anything gay i'm going to
ruin your career right oh my god but it
was you know what to me it was sad